hallo mein name ist luca ruch new space
oder das einfach mal dass mir dieser
behinderten bettringen
wir machen heute mal wieder ein quiz und
zwar wie gut gibt wieso habe ich das
macht gar keinen sinn dass ich kein ton
an alle die neu sind beim einem kanal
hey ich bin blöd geht am besten wieder
alles klar
als der anschlag mein ziel für youtube
ist es dass ich irgendwann so eine
kleine zuhörerschaft von vielleicht zwei
oder gar keinen leuten habe die dann
einfach meine wir fangen wie gut kennst
du komm crafter es geht um luca toni
konnten kräfte blues oder wie auch immer
ich so viele namen wie high score
crafter in echt ist mir egal wie alt ist
conny 19 ist wie genau sogar die frage
120 17 400 milliarden oder irgendwie so
richtig dumm was sind das für ersteller
von den tests alter schreibt einfach hin
ist mir egal 20 17 4 milliarden
ich bin 19 meine damen und herren ich
werde am 21
das ist nämlich auch schon die dritte
frage dann was für videos macht conny
let's play youtube ganz klar beauty auch
sein als die antwortmöglichkeit fünf mir
immer noch egal ich würde meine videos
er unter komödie packen als unter let's
play weil ich ja eigentlich nicht let's
play let's play ist für mich so lasst
uns zusammen spielen doch ich mache
definitiv let's play ich weiß nicht für
mich ist let's play so definiert ok
kommen wir nehmen ein spiel und spielen
es von anfang bis ende durch sowas was
sarrazin oder grund machte die machen
das gut gar keine frage ich würde mich
überhaupt nicht in diese schiene
einordnen sondern ich würde mich mehr
schon sind mittlerweile als
unterhaltungskanal sehen weil ich nicht
spielen kann in welchem netzwerk ist
luca studio 71 wieso mache ich dieses
quiz die move was ist ein netzwerk kann
man das essen keine ahnung ich bin dem
netzwerk studie 71 wenn er derzeit
supertoll zufrieden
wie viele videos hat conny zu zeitalter
ich habe über er hat keinen kanal mehr
irgendwann ist dann tatsächlich auch die
softbox ist alles alles okay alles
kommen mir nicht zu nahe ich kam mir
gerade so ein bisschen so vor wie dieses
facebook video von diesem polizisten so
kommen wir nicht so da ich kann mich
verteidigt mit der hälfte
ich bin in gefahr nico ist dieses klaus
ideen darauf hat möchte ich das immer
abkoppeln
das ist für die bühne geboren verhüllt
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung mit
der videos ich habe ich würde sagen 1591
aber es stimmt auch nicht weil das quiz
ja auch ständig und blatter jeden tag
was neues hoch wie viele abonnenten hat
luca 10 eine million 902 dafür eine zahl
war es mir gar kps doch dieses mal ist
doch ich glaube ich habe null abonnenten
wie heißt die ukulele von luca entweder
meint der größer stelle jetzt wie die
heißt oder wie heiß sie ist es ist mir
egal wie heißt der hund von lukas
schreibweise balu heißt ja auf jeden
fall und die letzte frage wie halt lukas
flasche ich will einfach die auswertung
es ist einfach nichts davon richtig wie
heißt die hello mit doppel t vitello
benannt nach der wasserflaschen marke
benannt nach vittel und vittel wird mit
doppeltem geschrieben und vitello wird
zwar wie halo ausgesprochen aber reicht
der wird halo heißen ich sehr jung ist
das quiz bist du hübsch ich würde mal
einfach sagen dass der künstler steller
dachte vitalis richtig aber wie
tätowiert mit doppel t geschrieben
jetzt haben alle verstanden war richtig
gut lobte den der aus und wie viel hat
sich jetzt richtig das zweite kurze
scheinbar oder falsch christ über die
gut kennt zukommt also genau das gleiche
er hat eine game die aus fünf leuten
bestehen inklusive kong crafter label
emi vitello ball ruhig
wir sind fünf bei der gern gibt es einen
hund namens mu falsch ukulele und
vitello sind bei einem akinator video
entstanden war kraft an der tu kollege
auffallend war er hat fakten videos über
war die flasche wieder los von der marke
evian
was ist denn ewig und kraft das der
beste natürlich konkret hat eine million
abonnenten 2015 war er hat ein match wo
sich zwei die oliver nennt wo sich
smiley hat einfach dieses label das hört
was ich gerade an hab ist übrigens neu
im store das trage ich seit dem
irgendwie täglich so hat vorher das ist
vom stoff ich hatte noch nie so ein t
shirt mit sauerstoff das ist für mich
irgendwie so ein bisschen das ist mein
lieblings geworden weil für mich ist das
irgend so eine art rico stoff so ein
bisschen aber irgendwie auch mit kauft
einfach du bist ein richtiges pferd
du bist ein fan von craft und verfolgt
ihn vielleicht schon lange wir haben
neun von zehn
was hatte ich denn falsch bestimmt wo
das quiz einfach gemacht bevor der play
button zu der gern gehört hat das könnte
der fehler sein wenn euch das video
gefallen hat meine lieben freunde würde
ich mich über eine bewertung freuen wenn
wir 70 millionen likes knackig auf die
wand schräg senkrecht und dann würde ich
sagen sehen wir uns
in einem nächsten video wieder nein ich
mache es nicht